Gamora from Guardians of the Galaxy knows
better than anyone else that parents just
don't understand — especially when they're
power-hungry madmen like Thanos who aren't
your real dad anyway.
"I hope they remember you."
After ten years and 18 movies, Marvel Studios
finally pulled the trigger on having the Mad
Titan Thanos go toe-to-toe with the Avengers.
But while everyone knows the Eternal's main
mission is to acquire all six stones for the
Infinity Gauntlet, a big part of that mission
revolves around his adopted daughter, Gamora.
But how did this relationship begin in the
first place?
It changes depending on whether you're talking
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe or the
comic books, and also depending on which comic
you're reading — but the general skeleton
of their relationship remains the same no
matter what.
Forget the finer details — this is all the
stuff you need to know about the relationship
between Thanos and Gamora.
As established in the comics, Gamora is the
last surviving member of a pacifist race called
the Zen-Whoberis— or Zehoberei, as they
say it in the MCU.
When she was a young girl, her people were
completely wiped out by a powerful invading
force.
Afterwards, Thanos discovered her alive and
decided to adopt her, seeing great potential
in her as a deadly warrior.
On the surface, that's pretty selfish — but
in an accidental fashion, it's also sort of
nice.
That act of compassion for the sake of violence
in the midst of utter destruction would do
a lot to warp Gamora's developing mind in
the comic canon — but in the movies, it's
so much worse.
In Gamora's comic origins, it was the evil
Magus and his Grand Inquisitors who destroyed
her race.
But in the movies, it's established that Thanos
himself is the one who exterminated her folks,
giving their relationship an intense and complex
twist with an icky undercurrent of emotional
abuse.
Over the course of her childhood and adolescence,
Thanos was a stern disciplinarian of a father
who only occasionally betrayed his compassion
for his ward, and the harsh upbringing hardened
Gamora into exactly the sort of warrior Thanos
wanted her to be.
But in spite of his goals of galactic domination
and mass murder, he's not 100% evil.
Regardless of everything else, Thanos does
love his adopted daughter in his own weird
way.
While he's violent and harsh to Gamora, he's
flat-out murderous to anyone who hurts her.
The ninth issue of Warlock and the Infinity
Watch sees Gamora get attacked by a group
of violent crooks who outnumber and outmatch
her.
While she was saved by Thanos, it was only
after the gang had already brutally beat her.
Her body broken, Thanos demonstrated his peculiar
compassion by nursing her back to health,
making her better, stronger, and faster than
she was before, replacing her entire skeleton,
and enhancing her reflexes, respiratory system,
and physical strength.
He also removed her tear ducts, so that the
young woman with the unspeakably hard life
would never know sorrow again, which may not
be how that works, on any level, but says
a lot about Thanos' mindset.
Gamora stayed a ward of Thanos into adulthood,
sticking by her guardian's side until she
discovered Thanos' genocidal ambitions, which
he intends to realize with the full power
of the Infinity Gauntlet.
That realization was all the inspiration she
needed to turn against the Titan.
Once she realized that her adopted father's
obsession with death on a massive scale was
the real deal, she set out on her own, finally
able to develop her own moral compass separate
from Thanos, the Worst Dad Ever.
No spoilers here, but a major aspect of Avengers:
Infinity War revolves around Thanos' genuine
love for Gamora, giving the Death-obsessed
Titan a disarming amount of emotional complexity.
But that compassion is outweighed by almost
everything else Thanos does, leaving Gamora
with no choice but to stand against the man
who raised her, and made her who she is.
That should catch you up on just about everything
you need to know about Thanos and Gamora's
relationship.
See where it all leads in the certified-fresh
Avengers: Infinity War.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!